let's go to scott from trenton scott
from trenton what is on your mind
hi good morning can you hear me yes i
can hear you
excellent i just wanted to know um
coming from i'm from canada and i'm just
wondering how
you have 40 of the population who who
actually supports donald trump and
what do you think that they're going to
do say
when biden wins so this is trenton
ontario is that what's going on
yes uh okay i i couldn't see it i
assumed it was maybe uh
new jersey it would be right there's a
trenton in new jersey i think
in any case listen i understand your
shock and amazement that
you know tens of millions of people in
this country are voting for donald trump
i have raised this issue many times if
biden wins and let's not assume but if
biden wins
what happens to those 60 million people
in the interim period between
election day and inauguration day i
believe there's a real possibility that
they become violent including with
firearms
beyond that i don't know what happens
you know they
uh i think a lot of them are going to
pretend like they never really
supported trump some of them may split
off into some kind of
q anon conspiracy rabbit hole that maybe
at some point will become a more formal
political movement
it's very very difficult to say but
they're going to be here and we're going
to have to deal with it as a country and
i don't know exactly how we do that
yeah i i just i watch your show or
listen to your show all the time
and i i'm just genuinely concerned that
um the us has has withdrawn its
role as being the leader of the free
world and
um what's what's going to happen
i just don't know how it proceeds or
progresses from here
i don't know either i'm just so what i'm
trying to do is to
take it step by step have i voted yes
okay i did that
uh next let's see what happens on
tuesday and then we'll
continue to to make plans after that
yeah okay well big fan thanks for taking
my call appreciate it great to hear from
you very very much
today one of our sponsors is surf shark
which is a premium vpn service
they're giving my audience 83 off a
two-year plan
plus three extra months for free coming
out in total to about
two bucks a month it's 2020 if you're
not already using a vpn
now is the time to start vpns hide your
ip address online
protects you from government
surveillance big tech companies
can't track you online and internet
service providers won't be able to
log and sell your internet history surf
shark is the vpn i trust because they
don't monitor or log your internet
activity like many other vpns do
it encrypts your data you can install it
on unlimited devices
it can block ads protect you from
malware and phishing
and it even lets you stream tv shows and
movies
that are only available in other
countries surf shark is giving my
audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra month free so that comes out
to just about two dollars a month which
is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have while browsing online
just go to surfshark.deals
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman